(beaming music)
- Okay, so I want
to introduce to you
a guy that you guys
know very, very well,
Mr. Aaron Price.
We're making a
very special introduction
for my main
man GaryVee, alright?
(cheering)
- Hello, there we go.
What's up, everybody?
(cheering)
- I got the captain's chair.
- [Gary] Hello.
- What up, Jersey?
- How many people here
know the Gary Vaynerchuk?
(audience cheering)
How many people have been
provided what he loves to call,
I think it's so
appropriately identified,
value from his content?
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- If you don't know Gary--
- Before we do that, let's clap
it up for this fucking day.
How nice is this?
That's the real
star of the show.
Forget the panels.
The fucking sun came out.
- And that brings us
to our first question.
- Yes.
- Gary talks about
knowing his audience.
- Yes.
- There's a varied
group of attendees here.
- Yes.
- Corporates, maybe some kids.
- Yep.
- And we're cursing.
- Yeah, I always curse.
- Yeah, I know.
- I like cursing.
- We've talked about this.
- Yes.
- If you could prevent it,
would you?
- I mean, look,
I've been on TV 200 times.
I haven't cursed.
I understand it's inappropriate,
and I'm not unaware
that 20 people just now are
like, "Oh, that's off-color.
"I don't like that."
I respect that, I have
empathy for how I'm consumed.
It's just when I see this many
people, I default into that,
I default into my Jersey
stuff, I default into
what Eddie Murphy
and Richard Pryor did
that I was obsessed
with as a kid,
so that's just what happens.
And at some level, I think
a lot of you know this,
at some level in life, whether
you got lucky like I did
at a very young age,
or when you're 90,
somewhere along the line
you start realizing that
it's not about who cares
what other people think?
It's if you feel good
about your intent
and don't think you're
trying to do something wrong,
you have to let the chips
fall where they fall.
And so for me,
that's what it is.
It's, I'm not upset or
disappointed or confused why
somebody doesn't like the
bravado or the cursing,
I just have made a choice,
that I'm not trying
to do anything wrong.
It's how I communicate and
you just have to move forward.
- [Aaron] And I'm not
criticizing you.
I'm thinking about, there
are strategic relationships
of potential--
- I know how to make money.
I'm never scared
of losing money.
- Have you ever lost a deal
because of the language?
- [Gary] 100%.
- Yes.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Didn't care?
- Nope.
- Where you from originally?
- Because it's a
net-net score, right?
This is a good thing for
a lot of the entrepreneurs
and business people out here.
Way too many people play in
what's only in front of them
without understanding
the net-net score.
So, seven years ago,
I started an agency
that was selling people
something they didn't want.
It wouldn't have been hard for
me to figure out how to sell
PR, or television, or
SEO, but I didn't want to
because I knew where
the puck was going.
I knew where social was going.
And so I was okay with losing
deal after deal after deal
in 2009, '10, '11, which
I did, because I knew
I was affecting the people
in the room with my thesis
and I knew that
I was gonna be right.
And now in 2016, '17, '15,
a lot of those same people
who laughed me out of the
room, who thought I was wrong,
are coming back and
giving me a lot of money
because I played
out to be right.
So in the net-net of
a decade, I won,
even though maybe I lost in
that year or two or three.
- So, you have the good fortune
of being more right than wrong.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Most people are
more wrong than right.
- [Gary] That's why
I'm sitting up here.
(laughs)
- How--
And that's just true.
- Yeah, that's the game.
- That's the game, that's right.
By the way, and you
know what I love?
That if I do my videos
and spew my shit
and for the next two years
I'm just wrong, wrong,
wrong, wrong, wrong.
Then I don't deserve
to sit up here,
and so I love the
meritocracy of that.
I'm not sitting up here
because I'm cute or I'm cool.
I'm sitting up here because
I've been right enough
and I bring people value in
that rightness, if they decide.
I've had 40 people in
the last month email me
that they've made 10s
of thousands of dollars
being a Snapchat filter designer
when they had eight bucks
in their bank account.
That's why they wanna drive
from Philly and see me.
Right?
That's why,
not because I'm clever.
Because I realize that if I can
bring more value than I take
back in return,
then I'm valuable.
And I think that people are
way too short-sighted and
are looking for
short-term results
and are not looking
to provide that,
and are looking at from
what's in it for me?
and that's just not how I see it
because I don't think
business is a one-year game.
If I did, by the way,
let me save you time.
If you start seeing
my behavior cashing in
and trying to extract, then
you know that I've decided
in 24, 36 months, it's a wrap.
Right?
That I don't need it anymore,
but doing the right thing
upfront always brings
long-term value.
- So tell people when, you
had a book launch, right?
- Yep.
- There was a lot of lead-up--
- Yes, I was selling
hard for 3, 4 months.
- Tell people, if they
haven't read the book,
in a minute or less,
what's the jab and when is
the appropriate time to
bring the right hook?
- Oh, so you mean
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook?
You know,
it's a thesis I believe in.
Give value, give value,
give value, and then ask.
I think a lot of you out
there that do know my stuff,
some of you have confused
it as give, give, give
and then take.
I've had a lot of people ask
me why they didn't convert
and when I look at their
tactics, it's 'cause they're
trying to take,
they're not asking.
So for me, if you've watched
every video that was free,
if I emailed you
back four times,
if I've responded to
you six times on social,
if I shook your
hand four times here,
and then book number five
comes out and you decide
not to spend that $18,
I'm not crippled by that.
Because I don't think any
of my actions that I'm doing
entitle me to anything from you.
I think what they entitle
me to is a solid ask
that feels appropriate, but
if I convert, that's really
up to the quality of what
I'm delivering for you
at that moment, and I think that
way too many
people are entitled.
I think way too
many people are entitled,
I think way too many people
complain, it just is what it is.
The market doesn't care, right?
The market, the game, doesn't
care where you grew up,
or your mom didn't do this
for you, or you don't have
any good developers around you.
It just doesn't care.
It's the market, and you
have to adjust to that
and so I equally do that.
When you're at the top or
doing well, you're only as good
as your last at-bat.
It doesn't matter
that I've been good
at business for 20 years.
If I suck in 2017 and '18,
I'm gonna lose.
- So, there's a, you know
the whole ethos of Propeller.
- Yes.
- Is what we say idle
ideas don't fly, right?
And there's a lot of people,
who I wonder,
are sittin' in maybe a cubicle
and watchin' your stuff,
gettin' all fired up,
but not taking their
ideas to the next level.
What do you tell those guys?
Some of those guys,
by the way, feel like
maybe they can't take the risk,
maybe they've got
young kids at home,
they don't have the
financial where-with-all.
- I tell them that I respect
them and I understand.
And I tell them to do
the best job they can
to try to feel what
it might feel like in
30 or 40 years if they
don't at least try.
I think regret is
the scariest feeling.
And I think,
I think if you really
analyze 70, 80, 90-year-olds
that lost a lot of money,
don't have a lot of money
versus ones that are okay,
but have a lot of regret
of never going for it.
It's a pretty interesting
conversation.
Even the cameraman here
is givin' me a little love
on that shake.
It's an interesting
conversation,
that when I look at
an 80-year-old
who was middle-class
but loaded with regret
because he didn't have
the guts to go for it,
versus somebody who
didn't have a lot of money
and had to struggle and
things of that nature
like it's just funny,
the person with regret
feels more in pain and
I try to talk about that
because, ya know,
I just think it's real.
And then, you know,
I had video recently go
quite crazy on Facebook,
that I was talkin' to
22 to 25 year olds.
I think it's extremely practical
to be high risk in the first
five years out of college
even with debt sitting there.
Because at 27, 28 you're
more than welcome to get that
standard stable job and
just chip away with it.
But at that first five
years, you can go after
all your dreams, and ambitions
and thoughts and needs.
And so, it's an interesting
theme what people react to.
I think a lot of it has
to do with regret.
And I think my
intuition about
being an old soul,
and spending time with
older demo people
has given me some vibe
that makes me say
"Shit, it doesn't
matter what you think
"when you're 20, 30, 40."
It matters, but you're
makin' decisions on how you
think you're gonna
feel at 60 and 70.
And if you actually listened
to 60, 70, and
80-year-old people,
it's just not how it plays out.
So, why don't you figure
that out and reverse it back.
- What do you think about the,
you know, start-ups
are hot shit right now.
You got a lot of young kids
and older people
raising capital.
But what do you think,
you know,
do you think it's over--
- [Gary] I think it's--
- celebrated?
- It's definitely
over celebrated.
- [Aaron] Welcome to Propeller.
- Like,
(crowd laughing)
Like, it's the most
over-celebrated thing
going on right now.
Like, yo, I'm a founder.
Cool.
Like, you've raised
a lot of money,
you've never
accomplished anything.
Like "I'm an entrepreneur"
is like sayin',
"I sing songs" right?
Like, but do you make
money singing songs?
Are you Beyonce?
Like, just because
you're an entrepreneur,
doesn't mean anything.
And everyone's like,
"Yo, I'm an entrepreneur."
I'm like "Cool, are you
a winning entrepreneur?
"Are you a money-making
entrepreneur?"
Like "Will you be an
entrepreneur in four years
"when the economic
meltdown comes
or are you gonna be
workin' at J.P. Morgan?"
So, I think shit's ugly.
I think a lot of
people I just met
will be out of business 'cause
they don't have a business,
they have an idea and
they're tryin' to raise money.
Money's gettin' tighter.
It's about to get real tight
in the next five to ten years.
Nobody knows.
It could happen tomorrow,
but it's comin'.
There's a lot of
indicators of like,
China's propelling
up the global economy,
like, faking it.
It's comin', it's coming.
And so if you're in
the audience right now
with your start-up,
I'm gonna give you one
really good piece of advice,
I truly believe it is.
Start figuring out
how to make money.
Because if you're sitting
right now and you burn,
and your life depends on
raising your next round,
or your first round,
you are extremely vulnerable.
And I highly recommend,
and I don't care how
bright the sun is shining,
and I don't give a
shit how delicious
the Red Bull fuckin' tastes.
You better get real fucking
practical right now,
'cause shit's comin' down.
- [Aaron] Thank you to
our sponsors, Red Bull.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
- If, yeah
- Because!
Let me tell you why!
Because you have to
understand what happens next.
And this is happening,
generation,
this happens every ten years.
What happens next is,
you go and get a job.
Stop being not practical.
And then, I mean
it's just unbelievable.
And there's plenty
people with jobs,
and I'm not sayin', I mean,
I love jobs.
I've always had a job.
Being the founder of a business
that doesn't make money,
is losing not winning.
Until you've turned
it into making money,
you're losing!
And all of you think
you're winning.
Why?
'Cause you said you
were a fucking founder?
- [Aaron] So listen,
let's dig in on that though.
'Cause I know one of the
things you love to reference
is one of your early calls
that Instagram was a cheap buy.
Right?
- [Gary] Yes, and I took
a lot of fucking heat.
- That's right.
- That it was
a billion dollars, I was stupid,
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
- And how much
revenue did they bring in
when they were bought?
- Zero.
- Exactly, so how
do you differentiate,
like there are guys out there--
- There was fucking a
hundred million people
using it in four minutes.
You got a hundred million users
on your fucking dick shit app?
- But it starts with one.
- If you do, good, you won!
Come talk to me,
I'll give you more money.
- I love getting Gary fired up.
- No, but I mean, what's
the difference between
Instagram and my shit?
A hundred fucking million
users of this product, asshole.
- [Aaron] But they started,
they started with one.
- You've got like four fucking,
yes they started with one,
but in fucking four minutes,
they had 50,000, 400,000.
You've been at it for 18
months and nobody gives a fuck.
It's time to rethink that shit.
- That the heart of my question.
For people here who have ideas,
that don't have
built-in revenue models--
- That's fine.
- How long do they go before
they say, "You know what?
"I'm not Instagram."
- I'm not fucking Nostradamus.
I have no idea.
Here's what I know.
I know that the
first thing you should do
is stop lying to yourself.
I wish I was the quarterback
of the New York Jets
and six-four.
Guess what, I'm not.
And way too many people
here are hoping and dreaming
that they're an entrepreneur.
If you are in your
mid-to-late 20s or older,
and you've never
really made money,
and I mean slingin'
Blow Pops in sixth grade,
I mean burning music on
a CD and flippin' it,
I mean, fucking, ghetto
fucking entrepreneur shit,
and now you're 26 and you've
never really made money?
You're in trouble.
Like, you've gotta
understand who you are.
Guess what?
The 41st person that
worked for Facebook
made a fuck-load more money
than most anybody else.
There's way too many of you
sitting on the grassy
knoll right now
that would be unbelievable
number fours, sevens, 18s, 32s,
and could make a lot
of money, be happy,
have a great work-life balance,
not deal with the
insane pressure
and the fuckin'
suicidal thoughts,
and the depression, and
the fucking I don't wanna,
everybody in my family
said it wasn't gonna work
and now it's not gonna work
and they're gonna be right
and I'm gonna have to eat that
shit for the rest of my life.
All that shit,
if you just deployed some
self-awareness up front
and didn't get romanced
by entrepreneurship
being the cool thing.
And, I'm very passionate
about that because,
right now it's all fine,
and ha-ha,
Gary's making funny jokes,
yeah, he's saying
it straight, cool.
You have to understand,
there's an enormous amount
of pain on the back end of this.
It's real.
It's emotional pain,
it's financial pain,
and that scares me.
And I want to talk about
it because it's real.
And it's not because I'm right
or because I'm winning
and you can't.
It's because it's data.
Just look what's happening.
Look what's happening.
Every trend of what's getting
funded, who's winning,
who's going out of business,
looks exactly like
the early 2000s.
Looks exactly like
the mid-2000s.
Like, it's here.
It's here.
And, just like every time,
it's one event.
It's one big start-up
that none of us think
could go out of business,
closes its doors.
Right?
It's one report that scares
every VC out of their skin.
And that's it.
And so ...
It's not like,
go get a job, you suck.
It's, how practical are you?
Are you just dreaming?
- [Aaron] How many people ...
Every time we've met,
there's a line out the door
of people wanna
to pitch you ideas.
How many of those,
percentage wise, are good?
Do you think are
investible or have legs?
- One percent.
- And that sounds high.
So, what do those
other 99 guys do?
- I mean, listen,
you have to understand,
just 'cause you're
a human being,
doesn't mean you're
entitled to be
a successful entrepreneur.
They do what everybody
else does in every genre.
You wanna be an NFL
player and a NBA player,
you try, you're not good
enough, you do something else.
You wanna be a famous actor,
you go to LA, you wait tables,
you try to be on a show,
it doesn't happen,
you do something else.
I don't know what they do.
Like, something else,
but they're not gonna build
a million dollar business.
Guys?
Do you know how many
million dollar businesses
are actually built that sustain?
Like, the data is
not in our favor.
And I'm not trying to
be cloudy in this sun,
I'm trying to save people
some money and some heartache
and create some upside.
This is just practicality.
It's just data.
We're not talking about it.
And, listen, a lot of
you know my spiel.
I'm not excited
to talk about this.
I'm happy-go-lucky,
I'm positive, I'm crush it.
But I'm fuckin'
telling you the truth.
It's just here right now
and what that means,
by the way, let me explain.
A lot of you have businesses
that actually
could be successful.
The problem is you
have 17 employees
when you should have 5.
A lot of you have businesses
that could be successful
but you wanna have a nice
office, right, in SoHo,
instead of being
somewhere shitty.
Right?
Like, a lot of you could have
businesses that are successful
but you come to
fucking Propeller
and waste time instead of
building your business.
- Whoa, whoa, what, what?
No, no, no, no,
not that last part.
- That last part and
all the other shit.
Like, are you
building a business?
Like, you better
fucking work tomorrow.
And the only reason
some of you will
is 'cause it's gonna rain.
'Cause if it was like
this today, tomorrow,
you'd all be somewhere
and that's just losing.
And that's happening at scale.
- So look, right?
One of the things that
I promised people here
is that we will
help them save time
in building their businesses
from listening to guys like you
and the hundred other
speakers that we have.
- Okay.
- So, I'd argue that point,
a bit,
'cause I do think you
need to stay connected
and stay educated and
stay on your A-game.
- Yes, but
you have to have a
foundation of something.
- [Aaron] But there's a
million want-repreneurs, right?
- Yes.
- How many 25-year-olds come
up to you with a cool idea,
looking for a check, and
thinking they're gonna go
buy the fancy SoHo office?
- [Gary] Of course.
And, by the way, a good
percentage of them
are gonna win.
I hope you're sitting
there and getting mad at me
and saying, "Fuck this guy."
And I can't wait to get
your email saying,
"Oh, you said I wasn't
gonna win at Propeller.
"I built a hundred
million dollar business."
Respect.
Great.
I want that.
I hope every fucking person
looking at my face right now
wins everything.
Money, life, health.
Great.
I want that more than anybody.
Why not?
Be the greatest.
I just think there's
an enormous lack of
practicality right now.
- Alright, let's move in
the positive direction.
- That was positive.
That was the positive direction.
- Let's move more in
the positive direction.
- That was the positive.
- Let's follow up on that
and keep that train going.
- I think that's positive.
- I agree.
- Instead of people
pontificating here like,
"Yeah, we're all
gonna fuckin' do it."
- Unfortunately--
- [Gary] I think
that's negative.
I think that's horseshit.
- That's the whole
point here, right?
Expose people to what
works and what doesn't work
so they can fail faster.
So, if somebody here has an idea
- Yes.
- Step one?
- Build it.
- When do they fund it?
When do they call you?
- Never.
- When do they go to Vayner/RSE?
- Never, if they
can pull it off.
Why give up your business
if you can build it?
Build an app and get a
job on the side, hustle,
and fuckin' make money and put
it back into your business.
It's easy to raise money.
And, what's funny is,
a lot of you are like,
"Fuck, I'm struggling."
Well, then you really suck.
(audience laughs)
- [Aaron] The
struggle's real.
When was the last time you were
depressed about
entrepreneurship?
- Never.
- [Aaron] Never...
- No, because I,
it's my calling,
it's the only thing I ever
wanted,
it's why I was depressed
in school my whole life,
this was the game I was
born for, this is all I know,
I would suffocate if
I couldn't do this,
I love when bad days,
yesterday was a shit day,
the shit, fuckin' shit,
like 21 hours--
- [Aaron] Hey, how was yesterday?
- Shit.
(audience laughing)
Like, so many bad things
happened yesterday,
yesterday was shit,
like on--like terrible.
But I love it because--
- [Aaron] Business or personal?
- Business, but like, it's
great, it's much better
than fuckin' doin' something
that I don't wanna do.
- [Aaron] But there must be
times, when maybe you don't feel
depressed, but you feel
the struggle, right,
you feel like yesterday.
- The struggle?
Every second. Every day.
- Right, so you wake up today,
right, what keeps you goin',
what keeps you
jumpin' outta bed?
- I have no other option.
This is my oxygen, I wasn't
into other shit like you were,
this is all I ever knew, I'd
fuckin' pick flowers and sell
it at four, lemonade--my hobby
in the summer was washing
people's cars for money.
- How many people here did
stuff like that, wash cars,
lemonade stands,
hack shit at school?
- And so you know, that's
how they're wired, like me,
like that's all you knew,
like my brain never thought,
oh, let's go play Nintendo,
my brain was like,
yo, let's go buy a Nintendo
and sell it, I'm gonna rent
cartridges, like that's
just all I've ever knew,
I don't have another gear,
I'm fuckin' basic,
I'm one-dimensional.
- Man, I think that's awesome,
I think that's why you're
so celebrated, right,
but there's a lot of people
here who aren't wired that way,
and I don't think we wanna--
- And they're lucky, this sucks.
(audience laughing)
- But we don't wanna
discourage them,
there's some successes--
- I'm not discouraging them,
I just said they're lucky,
do you know how much
I wish I wasn't so insane?
Like, do you know how
much more fun it would be,
I would be thrilled to leave
20% of the money and the action
and the selfies on the table,
for a couple more vacations,
to watch, it'd be fun to know
what the fuck's on Netflix,
you know, like, I wish,
by the way, I'm not joking,
I'm not telling people to be
like me, this isn't great,
this is just who I am.
- Let's talk about that
self-awareness, right,
'cause that's the key to this.
You are authentically you.
- Yes.
I try very hard.
- And I think the key point
here is we're not saying,
be like Gary.
- [Gary] No, I'm saying,
be like you.
- Yeah, and how do people find
that, how do people
find that thing that's
authentically them?
- I don't know.
I really don't.
- How do they know when
it's not?
- The results.
- [Aaron] There are some people
who will be authentically
themselves in a shitty business,
and it won't work--
- Great, they may have
everything else going for them.
- And you tell those guys what?
Try again?
- Mazel Tov.
No, I mean, what do you mean,
like, everything's going
great for you, but you
can't build a business?
Great, get an awesome
job that you like,
and your life is fuckin' set.
- How many times
should people, you know,
this here today is a result
of 15 years of hustle,
with one good business
and a dozen failures.
I kept at it, and I think we
got something pretty special
here.
- Yep.
- A lot of people
don't keep at it.
- Right.
- How, when do you know
when to throw in the towel?
- You know, I think that's
a personal question for
everybody, right, There's
family dynamics, you may have
a parent pass away, it might
be a good thing, you hit a
zone where you're content,
and this is what you want,
I don't think, to me that, you
can see my tone has changed,
I think is a very personal
question. You know,
it's hard to judge. I'm sure
there's plenty of people
who gave up one month before,
after doing it for three
years, and that next month
was gonna be the moment,
and that's sad, but I think
we all know there's so many
people that have gone
too far and too long,
and that hurt them.
I think that's comes down
to self-awareness
and looking at results.
Here's what I would say, guys,
it doesn't matter what I just
said for the last 20 minutes,
it doesn't matter the reverse
of my argument for the last
20 minutes, it's a constant
storm to try to figure out
what you're about,
and you change.
At 26, you're all about the
hustle, you're gonna be a
billionaire, this and that,
and then you go to the bar one
night, and you fall in love,
and it changes what you care
about, right, and then you
have a child, and then this
happens, and then that
happens, things change.
You just have to always
consistently try to figure out
what's driving you, and
not because other people
are watching, and not
because that's what your dad
wants, and not because that's
what you said was gonna
happen, and it doesn't look
like it and your family's
gonna judge you, you just
have to be as real with
yourself as possible, and
that is a very difficult
struggle, but when you're
not, you create enormous
vulnerability and unhappiness.
- [Aaron] And that can be
very problematic, personally
on the home life, right,
I mean how do you balance that?
- Over-communication.
You know, Lizzie and I talk,
and I never give people
relationship advice, and
people ask me all the time,
'cause a lot of you know
that I work so much,
and everybody has
different relationships,
and I have to over-communicate
with my wife and
understand how she's ticking
and what's making her happy
and what's not, and what she
said last week is irrelevant
to tomorrow, you know?
People are like,
oh, you said you were
gonna support me,
that was two years ago,
and things change.
And so it's a constant
stream of communication,
no different than what you
should be having with your
employees and your partners,
and you do that with your
spouse and your partner,
and things of that nature.
- What's the average
time you get home at the
end of each day?
- 11 PM.
- And you're offline weekends.
- Yes.
- Does that work?
- Yes, so far, but it might
change, and the kids are getting
older and it's not working for
me. One of the biggest things
that I wanna change going
forward is coming home around
dinner, and eat with them,
and then go back out,
and so that's something for
me. You know, like it evolves,
it evolves, I'm taking seven
weeks vacation now instead
of two, that's a lot,
that's a big change for me.
It evolves, so between weekends
and seven weeks vacation,
it's not like, you know
like, I don't know,
that seems like, I feel lazy.
- Yeah, man, you've got
to pick up your game.
- I'll try.
- How do you...
You mentioned that you
don't have time for Netflix,
you don't have time
for this other stuff,
but how do you balance
the time to figure out--
- [Gary] But, real quick,
I have time
for the Jets for seven hours--
- We know that.
- [Gary] You know,
16 times a year on a Sunday.
Everybody needs escapism.
You have to understand.
This is a great opportunity
with a lot of people watching
for me to clarify this.
I'm not judging you if you're
watching "House of Cards"
and playing Madden all day.
I'm judging you
if you're complaining
that you're not
successful professionally
and doing that all day.
Got it?
That's the distinction.
Do you!
Do you know how many
people are very happy
making $45,000 a year and
surfing every weekend?
Making $200,000 a year?
I'm not judging.
Who the fuck am I to judge you?
I'm judging the people that
email me every day saying,
"My shit's not working.
I'm not lucky, I don't get it."
And then are watching full
seasons of "House of Cards,"
playing Madden all day,
taking the entire weekend off.
I didn't take any
of my weekends off
for the first
15 years of my career.
Just so you know,
all of the venom is
for the complainers.
You're good?
You won.
- How do you stay,
though, with the curve?
How much time?
Number one, I think this is
one of the best
pieces of advice,
the most practical you give:
checking the top
100 apps in the App store
every single day.
You still do that?
- Every day.
- [Aaron] Did you do it today?
- Yep.
- [Aaron] See
anything interesting?
- Nope.
(audience laughs)
I only see something interesting
once or twice a year.
That's the point.
- What's your first
move when that happens?
You reach out to them?
- Attack. Yeah!
- [Aaron] Yeah?
- Phil Toronto on
my team, dig into this,
get me all of the information.
Set up drinks with a founder.
Find out if anybody invested.
Set up with them.
Audit.
All in, all fucking chips in.
Audit, audit!
- [Aaron] Made any
VR investments yet?
- No, but one's brewing.
- What do you think of that?
Where is it going?
- I think people are going
to lose a shit load of money
betting on VR consumer
over the next five years.
I think that there's a lot
of opportunity in B to B.
I think 15 years from now
VR is going to be a beast.
- [Aaron] We've got the
CMO of the Devils here today.
- Great.
- Who's going to put
headsets on Devils' masks,
so people can, at home, buy
tickets and watch via VR.
What do you think?
- I don't think
it's going to happen.
- [Aaron] I hope
he's not here yet.
(audience laughs)
- He won by doing it
because he wants the press
around doing it.
That gives
awareness to the brand
and that's a good KPI.
But do I think everybody
here is going to watch
the Devils' game
next year on VR?
I do not.
- [Aaron] What do you
think they'll do?
- When I say everybody,
this is an early
user crowd, right?
You're at Propeller.
I don't think a good
percentage of you will do it.
I definitely don't
think a good percentage
of Ricky Thompson, who
knows nothing about tech,
is going to do it.
That's when I care.
I care when Ricky Thompson
knows about Snapchat.
I care when Sally Arkansas
cares about Snapchat.
Not when Nerdy
fucking McGee is on it.
(audience laughs)
- [Aaron] I think he's here!
Nerd, where are you?
What do you think is
the number one use case?
I bring this up
because I think--
- Oh, it's going to take,
by the way,
VR is the only potential
arbitrage to the internet.
It's the next platform.
It just might be 15, 20.
What's it going to affect? Life!
Shopping, entertaining,
gaming, all of it.
Dating--
- You know what you're
leaving out, though?
The number one thing that
tends to push tech advancement
is porn.
That's where VR is
being pushed right now.
- I can't fucking
wait for VR porn.
- Would you invest in that?
- Maybe.
- Just to get the free headset?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
I just think even porn is
further away than people,
look, consumer behavior is
underestimated.
Guys, only 20% of products
are bought in e-commerce.
We're still buying in stores.
In 1996 when I started
WineLibrary.com, 1997,
if you told me that in 2016
only 20% would be e-com
I would've made fun of you.
You don't see the future.
You don't get it.
It takes time for
behavior to change.
For you to sit at
home and live your lives
through that world,
or spend a meaningful
amount of time will take time.
I actually believe
it will happen.
But I think it's
going to be a hell,
I think headsets will
never be at scale, ever.
Meaning, by the time it's at
scale we'll be on contacts
or some other version.
I don't think we'll ever
have mass headsets
at home doing VR.
Mass, mass, like everybody.
Maybe, but I just don't see it.
It's going to take too long
and there'll be
advancements on the headsets.
I've got to go, right?
- Yeah, we do,
hold on one second.
- Okay.
- The ethos of the
New Jersey tech meetup
and the ethos of this event is
about helping each other out.
- Great!
- What can we do?
What can people here do
today to help you out?
- Nothing.
- That's not true.
You can't leave here until
you think of something.
- Zero.
I'm super uncomfortable
with the ask.
I don't want anything
from you right now,
and that makes me happier
than coming up
with some bullshit ask.
- What can they do for
themselves that you believe in,
wholeheartedly, that
will make you feel good?
- Do something nice
for somebody else
that brings them value
without having expectations
of something in return.
Which is something
most of you can't do.
(audience claps)
- Ladies and gentlemen,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Thank you, guys.
- Hold on, buddy.
- Look up here.
- Much love.
Smile, hands up!
(beaming music)